[Musique]
sous la marche aux m'avait fait rire
avant le début de l'entrevue m'avait
regardé on dit en écoutant un film
capable de vous laisser aller est ce que
vous aimez salir dans les gens assez de
les analyser mais je pense que je ne le
sens pas il ya quelque chose d'assez de
boot est très instinctif dit je pense
que je suis une éponge aussi alors
probablement que j'ai dit vous éponge et
à un taux fixe est rentré puis c'est une
personne sensible on dit que vous avez
pleuré assez rapidement oui et
variablement presque tout le potentiel
de me faire pleurer
tout dépend de comment s'est présenté
moi y'a plein de gens aujourd'hui lors
qu'ils peuvent diriger cause sonia
vachon dans son auto à pleurer là ce que
moi je suis dans ma voiture et tout à
coup ça vieillit lol et l'âge même je me
mets à pleurer mais vous n'avez jamais
cherché à savoir pourquoi parce que vous
êtes toujours drôle à l'écran dans
l'univers de michel tremblay tiendront
dans les films vous êtes drôle puis dans
lorsque les caméras c'est dingue
vous êtes un peu plus la flore c'est
sensible oui ça ira et moi je dis
toujours que je te fais facile je suis
une montagne russe
cc c'est peut-être une chance
probablement une chance qui est ce
pendant la drôle qui aimeraient
ricaneuse qui a le rire facile qui est
de bonne humeur
parce que le docteur c'est carrément
pourtant ça fait pas fuir vos amis parce
que vous avez aimé le goudron vous avez
tourné cinq fois avec lui vous êtes
toujours dans l'univers de michel
tremblay
cette saison en virginie dans km à 5
saisons aura beaucoup d'amis par luis
que quand je tourne je m'en sers de ça
mais dans la vie ils savent rapidement
qu'ils doivent rire de ça avec moi de
7,2 ce moment de tristesse lors de ses
pleurs qui viennent et ils savent les
gens qui me connaissent savent qu'ils
doivent faire une farce ou une blague et
que c'est fini mais vous avez le métier
le plus dur au monde pour vivre
justement des montagnes russes parce que
des fois il n'y a pas de contrat des
fois vous avez des personnages plus
difficiles que d'autres des textiles
comprendre oui oui oui comme le red star
mais ça c'est ça fait partie de mon
métier c'est comme si je suis c'est le
pompier qui sort son équipement sur le
dos qui paye je sais pas moi salive mais
il rentre dans le feu alors c'est la
même affaire
ces mondes métier chez rien faire donc
moi c'est ça que je fais j'interprète
dans la vie alors c'est sûr que quand je
dois me servir de de métal à mais je
m'en sers et et je m'en sers j'ai le
droit
ça m'a pris m'appartiennent alors je
peux m'en servir comme je veux mais
c'est sûr que dans la vie je peux être
une montagne russe lors c'est probable
entrevue que j'ai fait la plus franche
de toute ma carrière mais c'est ça aussi
des hommes d'affaires
moi je veux pas être quelqu'un d'autre
ça me donne rien ça me donne absolument
rien d'être quelqu'un d'autre c'est ce
qui fait que c'est ce qui fait que je
connecte avec vous c'est ce qui fait que
cette agréable parce que moi là je
l'enlève
j'enlève les affaires moi je veux aller
la direccte direction là parce que ça tu
as un vent ça sert à rien et quand je
pas capable d'aller là lâche
complètement perdu je bafouille je sais
pas quoi dire j'ai impressionné jeu et
je dis ça sert à rien ça sert à rien
d'être quelqu'un d'autre moi je me
souviens qu'à j'ai terminé le
conservatoire de montréal
j'ai là j'ai vécu une grosse crise parce
que je n'étais pas capable de vendre
normal automne à paris des gens si le
bébé vomi qui s'étoffe tu le mets en
face tu suite ce même des fois mon agent
me disait parce que les personnes
peuvent user aux mots justes à vos
grands que j'allais dire ça je lui dis
je le lis diplôme dit essaie de dicter
au rôle que ce soit pas le droit de le
dire mais je pas capable je pas capable
parce que je me dis qu'est ce que ça
donne de donner une entrevue
si on dit parce que ce sont les choses
vraiment qu'on prend des notes à la mer
oui sur la bâche oh oui oh oui merci
merci à vous merci beaucoup